to folks in this region who are thinking
about making that dangerous trek
to the united states mexico border
do not come
i'm responsible for the decisions that i
make
i'm responsible for the actions of the
state department we made the right
decision in ending america's longest war
we don't own
our own gas supply or oil supply
and so
the market is what the market is
presidents don't control
the cost of gasoline why aren't school
employees public school employees going
back to work i don't have an answer for
you i mean i'd like to if i had that
answer i'd be given an all day today are
we addressing the chief of staff's
twitter habits is not a top priority
well that's just a taste of what the
administration has been dealing with on
a host of different fronts as you take a
look at this this graphic here you can
see each one of the members of the
administration from the white house
chief of staff ron klain with the high
class problems tweet vice president
harris and the border crisis uh
secretary of state on the afghanistan uh
testimony and and the situation the
attorney general about the parents and
as domestic terrorists the labor
secretary on the you just saw the labor
shortage we heard from secretary buda
judge the transportation secretary on
the supply chain issues uh the secretary
of energy on the gas prices uh the
secretary of department of homeland
security on the border disaster and the
crisis there and the secretary of
education dealing with critical race
theory and other questions
it's a lot
let's bring in our panel molly hemingway
senior editor at the federalist also
author of the new book rigged how the
media big tech and the democrats seized
our elections juan williams is a fox
news analyst and morgan ortegas former
state department spokesperson you know
when you put it in that frame morgan and
you were in an administration and
sometimes you had bad weeks or a couple
of bad weeks
but each one of those is a significant
issue that this administration is
dealing with
yeah at some point though you have to
get out of the bubble and this
administration has not yet been able to
get out of the bubble um in it really i
think is endemic of a crisis of
leadership right really if you ask the
american people who's in charge right
they don't they don't see joe biden as
being a leader if you look at all of the
polling and they don't see the vice
president either standing up and leading
on the positions that she said she was
going to and if you look at poll after
paul like quinnipiac for example uh just
25 of americans are approving of how the
president is handling uh the border and
then you go you check out at the grocery
store and your groceries are a lot more
expensive than they were a year ago or
six months ago so i don't think it's one
thing it's everything that you lay it
out in the beginning and the white house
and this administration needs to get
themselves out of the bubble and realize
it's not the you know commentators on
other cable news channels that determine
uh whether they get reelected or whether
they're doing a good job they answer to
the american people the american people
are hurting they're having a hard time
filling up their gas tank they're
worried about inflation
they're worried about the price of
groceries and they know that there is a
border situation that this
administration really has no honest
intention of solving anytime soon one
secretary buddha judged earlier i was
talking about this infrastructure bill
the bipartisan one that is up there
speaker pelosi has not put it for a vote
moderates would like her to take a
listen
why not move the infrastructure bill
that has that in it
that the house hasn't voted on because
the other bill is still being negotiated
and debated between democrats
well
we're for both of those bills i'm a
transportation secretary i'm also a new
father and i believe that the
president's overall vision of making
sure that this is a country where it's
affordable to raise a family
and making sure that we're supporting
americans with health care and making
sure that we deliver on these
infrastructure needs you know
all of these things fit together you
know one i went at it about three
different times they don't need
republicans to pass these things they
could put it on and take the bird in the
hand take the win take the w and the
secretary of transportation could have
better bridges and ports in airports
all true i i think it's very important
here to say you know republicans aren't
being supportive they were supportive on
the infrastructure bill but not on the
social infrastructure bill it's pending
so you have a division among democrats
and you have one segment of the
democrats using that bill as leverage uh
to make sure that they get the social uh
infrastructure that they want yeah but
one you don't need republicans right
just reconciliation you could pass the
whole thing you don't need them that's
what i said
that's why i said that right now you
have divisions among the democrats brit
and and what they want to do is use one
part the part that's already sitting
there passed by a bipartisan group in
the senate
as leverage to ensure that they get that
social safety net or social
infrastructure part passed i just wanted
to add quickly though that you know i
think a lot of this kind of carping at
the biden administration it ignores you
know this week we had such good news you
know the lowest number of unemployment
claims since the pandemic began gdp at
six percent i think that's the highest
in like 40 years
uh the stock market right now it's at
near record highs it's hit records for
the 50 times already this year i think
the american people are aware of supply
chain backers but they're also aware of
the pandemic and a lot of that's global
it's not caused by anything that we as
americans or joe biden has done yeah i
mean there are some good signs that you
mentioned there but the unemployment
number there's a lot of people out of
the workforce on that one um gallup
molly
the question was
government is it doing too much
preferences for government activity
doing too much or should do more and you
look at these numbers doing too much
is now leading exponentially
from year over year
and at the same time democrats are
pushing these uh trillion dollar bills
up on the hill i think one of the big
disconnects is people know that the
federal government is wanting to do a
lot of things and what they're doing is
failing at a lot of things you look at
all of these issues that you brought up
at the beginning whether it's the
debacle of the incompetence of how we
exited afghanistan a completely open
border as a result of the policies of
the biden administration and then when
you want to have a frank and open talk
about what everybody in the country
realizes is a suffering economy you have
a transportation secretary who sits
there and tries to say that actually the
economy is doing quite well whereas
normal americans know that that's not
the case and that the federal government
you know ostensibly in charge of some of
these things is doing a bad job of
managing supply chains or uh or other
issues that are leading to empty shelves
skyrocketing prices prices and they
don't seem to be taking it seriously
unless they take it seriously and it's
not just biden but all of these cabinet
officials less they take it seriously
the more anxiety it gives average
americans because they realize they're
not taking it seriously
you're gonna have to drop winners and
losers because uh just a few seconds ago
president baden was walking into the
residence he was asked about the
investigation into january 6th up on
capitol hill and he said that the
justice department should prosecute
those who refuse to testify and again
there are a number of people who've
already signaled that like steve bannon
not testifying he's saying the president
that they should be prosecuted by the
doj hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else